while William Pauley has defeated the
virus it is a growing problem in West
Africa it's killed over 1,500 people
there already and now the charity
Medecins on frontier has warned that the
world is losing the battle against the
disease have been joined by Vicky
Hawkins executive director of MSF UK
hello to you Vicky it is quite
remarkable when you see the pictures of
william cooley on the twenty-fifth of
august what 10 days ago coming back in
that isolation tent by the RAF and then
today sitting there looking a picture of
health but it's a very very different
story in West Africa isn't it absolutely
the situation in West Africa is
absolutely catastrophic and i'm really
not exaggerating when i say that MSF has
been responding to Ebola outbreaks since
the 1990s and this is way beyond
anything we've ever seen we're
absolutely in uncharted territory and we
don't know where it's going to go from
here in Liberia this situation is
particularly horrific our treatment
centers are full to capacity we have
people dying at the gates outside
because they can't get in and these are
the biggest treatment centers we've ever
run and is that because there is a lack
of staff there and obviously running an
Ebola response is a complicated
operation it requires a huge amount of
resources we have to have three staff on
standby for everyone staff that's
working in the treatment center itself
in case they developed a virus because
the time that staff are able to spend in
the treatment center is very limited
already we set the safety we set the bar
for our safety precautions extremely
heightened absolutely minimize the risk
to staff so it's a very very heavy type
of operation at the moment that it's
really been in the hands of MSF the
ministries of Health concerned and a few
other actors and we need much more
capacity much more resources dedicated
if we're going to defeat this it was a
month ago that we had the warding from
the World Health Organization wasn't it
that this was a public health emergency
of international concern and had the
international community stepped up to
that warning we don't think so
funding has been promised and funding is
indeed being delivered but it needs more
than that it needs manpower and what
we're really calling for is disaster
response to take Disaster Response Teams
with medical and logistical capacity to
get out there to West Africa boots on
the ground basically to build treatment
centers to provide greater numbers of
beds to assist with the problems of
disposing with with dead bodies and
really importantly we need an air bridge
because at the moment air links to West
Africa are reduced because the airlines
are cutting their services out of fear
of the disease and that obviously
impedes our ability to get personnel and
supplies to the search should those
flight cancellations be reversed then we
definitely call on air companies and
anybody with flight capacity to help
with this restore it appears that
flights international travel is
spreading the book the only way we're
going to defeat this this this this
outbreak is to actually treat it at
source at which we need people and
supplies to be able to reach West Africa
we've got some pictures that I think we
can show you now that we broadcast
yesterday I believed these are from
Monrovia and a bola victim who is
walking through the streets and you can
see others running away from him as the
medical workers in their full protective
gear at trying to catch him I think it
it just shows the sheer chaos and fear
that is out that absolutely you
absolutely right to talk about that
climate of fear the first time that West
Africa has experienced Ebola they
haven't seen it before people are
extremely scared and one of the negative
consequences of some of the measures
that have been imposed to try and to try
and quarantine populations is that it's
driven the outbreak underground that
people are suspicious of medical people
are suspicious of medical workers but
they're also hiding now they're trying
to flee and obviously that only
exacerbates the situation with william
cooley he was treated with zmap as a
drug we know that it's in short supply
we know that it's untested and is it the
wonder drug 32p
is to be when you see Western aid
workers and health workers making these
miraculous recoveries obviously there's
great promise but it's going to take a
very long time before something like
that can be rolled out at the scale that
we need in West Africa at the moment
what we need to do first and foremost is
concentrate on the tried and tested
methods that we have of controlling
Ebola which is basically building up the
number of treatment centers improving
the communication with the community so
that people we can reduce the fear
levels so that people know that they
need to bring patients into the
treatment centers so that they they can
be quarantined and they're not infecting
other members of the community